left feeling like weird about it and
then I knew I was gonna go do Jeff's
show on YouTube his Jeff's barbershop
show yeah he's like a barber and he cuts
people's hair and interviews them and he
kind of tries to make it like Eric Andre
sort of like like you sit down and he
like he like insults you a lot and he
like it's it's a lot of like surprises
right that's what it's supposed to be
right I come watch you know a few
episodes it's a great show I think it's
a great like like gimmick like cutting
peoples hair cuz it's like not only are
you there for the interview but you want
to see like how their hair turns out at
the end of it right it's like hot ones
or whatever yeah it's just like a nice
like layer on top of the interviews
alright so stoked to do it and I was
like I wonder what the [ __ ] is gonna
happen he was like I don't really have
anything written like I was just like
improv and I was like that's fine with
me
and so sat down cut my hair everything's
fine you know shows like going normal
like he's just like kind of insulting me
Jason Nash's there
Todd's there there you know kind of
roasted me at the same time like they're
adding their own questions Bob autumn
and I'm answering them and everything's
fine and then he jokes that Leigh Leigh
is gonna show up and I'm like ha that's
that's funny and he's like yeah no I
mean I I tried to she said that she was
down but her representation wouldn't let
her come to the show she said she wanted
to and I was like oh that would have
been that would've been really [ __ ]
funny he's like yeah I was gonna have
her curse at you in Spanish and all this
[ __ ] and I was like damn that would have
been a good that would've been a great
bit yeah and then he goes he goes um
it's like wrapping up the shows near the
end and so he goes who's by the way
who's your who's your least favorite
youtuber and I was like least favorite
he's like yeah I was like I don't know
and I made some stupid joke I was like
I'm I'm my least favorite youtuber and
yeah okay who's your second least
favorite youtuber and I was like I don't
know I didn't I couldn't think of an
answer so I just like you know knee-jerk
thing I was like Jake Paul he's like oh
okay
huh interesting that you would say that
and I'm like you know I'm like yeah he's
like yeah and then he's like yo Reggie
like open the door and his guy starts to
open the door and my having no [ __ ]
like you lately pawns if you couldn't
get lately pawns how yeah right like
there's a chance in [ __ ] hell Jake
Paul's gonna walk through that door
right now
and he opens the door and it's him and
I'm sitting there like I'm looking at me
as like don't worry if he tries anything
like I'm like I'm I told him I'm gonna
like not it's not cool for him to Ben
I'm like you know you didn't you just
you don't know if he's not gonna try
anything what the [ __ ] the kid you not
the kid walks up to me like he's gonna
fight like he walks like this like
beelines it towards me and I'm like yo
uh I don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on and he stops and he he starts calling
hey man um you know I really don't think
it's cool what you do I think you're a
cyber bully and I think that you I think
that you bully kids man and I'm like
what kids and he's like just like I
don't know like I've talked to like some
girls that you have laid into and it's
like they're like it's just not cool man
I'm not I'm not with that like I'm about
like spreading positivity no I swear
this is how I remember everything okay
this hour
I remember he's like yeah I just I'm
about spreading positivity and they're
like you're really not about that and I
just like I I don't [ __ ] with that or
whatever and I was like so my head I'm
like I don't know if this is a joke
right yeah is this a bit yeah did Jeff
and him talk about this beforehand I was
so [ __ ] confused yeah because I was
like he must have came here knowing what
Jeff's show was about yeah knowing that
it's about the shock value the the
element of surprise right and they did
that and now he's like you know kind of
like chewing into me and I'm like this
has to be a bit so I go I can't tell if
he's joking or not you think I'm not
joking bro and his camera dudes like
hammered hated me you could just tell
he's standing there [ __ ] shaking his
head and I'm like I I'm like okay I mean
like you can you could think that but
like I don't bully kids like I'm not
like I just it's just like [ __ ] for me
to write jokes I just need some to write
jokes about like I'm a comedian I like
write writing jokes and he's um he's
like he's still mad at me and I'm like I
can't figure out this is a [ __ ] bit
or not I keep looking at Jeff and he's
like Jeff's like very clearly like like
this is not a bit and so I and I still
can't tell if he's doing that for the
cameras all three cameras are on plus
Jake's camera right and so I'm still
like I'm still trying to
play into this thing where I'm like oh
maybe he expects us to [ __ ] make up
on camera like maybe that's that's what
the bit is right something like oh man
dude I'm sorry like I'm going like I'm
just talking I'm sorry like he's like aw
it's it's cool it's cool he apologized
it's cool and he dad stood me up and
then he's like shut to shut the cameras
off shut the cameras off and I'm like oh
so they shut the cameras off and I'm
like [ __ ] so you just like use this
oh yeah basically played Jeff for for a
cut for his own vlog where he can walk
in and confront me yeah and then like
make make me sort of like I mean like I
didn't have to apologize obviously I
just didn't know what else to do so
[ __ ] awkward I was yeah we're in this
tiny apartment yeah and it's for people
who are dead silent and then me and him
and I'm like what the and and dude Jeff
felt so [ __ ] bad he was like I had no
idea that's how that was gonna go I
thought it was he was stoked to come
like he came all the way from Calabasas
and and to do this and so afterwards
we're sitting there having like again
we're just like talk he's like I just
don't know why you do what you do and
I'm like explain I'm explaining to him
I'm like I this is why like I I I need
someone to write jokes about it's not
like I start a video and go I'm gonna
hurt this person's feelings say Gibby
you do that and I'm gonna keep I just
need something to write jokes about and
and this is this is the only thing like
it's it's like a it's an easy thing to
write jokes about especially like like
hi
especially when it's somebody that
everyone agrees is kind of goofy you
know I'm saying yeah and I'm like and so
I'm explaining this and a heat heat he
almost like just didn't really have [ __ ]
to say afterwards course not I felt like
course not it was weird it was like he
knew what he was gonna say before and
then we started having a real
conversation about it and he was just
like oh we've time I'll a light and I
was like like Leigh Leigh's a perfect
example like I can tell that her videos
are they don't put effort into them
they're just a cash grab you can tell
they're lazy the writing mode stuff
that's I'm irrelevant to them yeah it's
relevant to thing it's just it's very
transparent to me what they're trying to
do and I don't [ __ ] with that and so I
write jokes about it yeah and he was
like yeah but like but like her video
and like I could just he just didn't
have anything else to say after that he
was yeah but like you know I just feel
like kids
look up to you and they and they see
that and they think it's okay to make
fun of people I said look man off kid
fans I don't and he's like yeah but I
know dude I've met girls in for fifteen
sixteen seventeen that say you're their
favorite youtuber and I was like yeah
I'm not saying I don't have high school
fans I'm saying YouTube tells me he's 18
to 24 and podcast he's even older than
that excuse
more mail and he was like oh yeah I mean
like I don't know he was eyeing me down
the whole [ __ ] time and then and then
so like we like that was basically it
and then we like we like said goodbye
took a took a couple pictures when I
sent you where I'm just like yeah it's
happening yeah and he left yeah and then
we we oh yeah and in the video he says
um Jeff was like so what the next party
at your house he's not invited to he's
like no [ __ ] way
he's never coming over oh and then he
told me his brother wants to like his
brother hates me too Logan hates me cuz
this [ __ ] he's like he's like he's like
you guys he's like you're lucky this is
in like an environment where like
nobody's drinking it's [ __ ] like that
he's like if I would have seen you at a
party where we were drinking it would
have been like some confrontational [ __ ]
I don't know man I'm not I don't I'm not
a you know I'm not like a
confrontational dude I hate [ __ ] like
that I would have just been laughing I
was laughing because I couldn't figure
out like what the [ __ ] was going on I
was like I don't know I still don't know
how much of that was like sincere how
much that was like oh you're in we go
downstairs to like go for a hike and his
door his doorman was like hey he was
down here like we're Herzing what he was
gonna say oh yeah and shadowboxing
shadowboxing that's what he said I don't
know I don't know no Jesus Christ dude
how [ __ ] dense is this kid that he
doesn't under he doesn't actually
understand what jokes are doesn't
understand what commentary is just
completely devoid of [ __ ] brain cells
I don't know it's like you know you know
the whole thing was just weird I don't
really know what the thing about it I
don't like I don't know I don't know
it's weird like I can't I'm kind of glad
that it happened yeah I like that I'm
that I'm able to like talk about it now
you know I'm saying yeah
okay just I think it would be I don't
know I think it's pretty obvious which
how Jake Paul would react to people that
make fun of him in a closed setting like
everything you've told me is not at all
far from what I'd expect that's like
when Logan saw h3 at a party and Ethan
walks up to him and goes eh what's up
man like you know like you have of
roasted you but you know it like it is
what it is yeah you're you and I'm me
and Logan draws his [ __ ] arm back and
like and like closes his fist up to
Ethan's face or some and he's like this
um the effect of like if no one is here
that's what I would have done to you or
something like that and it's like okay
like the him like I guess what I'm
saying is for him to open the door and
beeline to you I would expect no less
cuz him and his brother seem like they
can't take criticism yeah I mean oh said
some [ __ ] where he was like yeah but
like you know why are all these people
you're making fun of like why do they
have such big fan bases why are their
videos getting two million views why
we're talking about Leila's videos why
do our videos get two million views why
is there so many people like liking them
and [ __ ] like that I'm like yeah but
there's just as many if not more people
liking my videos where I'm making fun of
him like that has to mean something too
I think that probably means more than
[ __ ] hurt video getting on the
trending page because she had some weird
relationship with YouTube you know I'm
saying right right and I think his logic
is it plays a certain way right like he
he's entirely about the numbers he's
always been you know yeah and and in his
mind he doesn't make a distinction so
what is two million views what if those
two million views are [ __ ] 8 to 12
mm-hmm and he doesn't consider that 8 to
12 like he keeps going and falling back
on oh but they're kids there are kids
that like it yeah and and maybe they
happen to stumble upon a video where
someone says wait a second this is
[ __ ] wack
and makes you think critically that's
what the [ __ ] that's how I got into
comedy and wanted to do stand-up I was
[ __ ] 8 9 10 11 years old I was
watching dudes 30 35 making observations
about the world it changed the way I
looked at the world and it made me think
more critically about myself yeah it
enabled me to have like a sense of
self-awareness and and not take [ __ ]
seriously it made me feel better about
like you know if kids were cooler than
me or kids were this and that like I
could look in the mirror and joke about
it I could joke about them and that was
my [ __ ] weapon against that [ __ ] and
when people like Jake when I was younger
who may have intimidated me that's what
in like people saying oh this [ __ ] is
lame or pointing pointing out that maybe
the [ __ ] that I thought was cool maybe
isn't so cool or it isn't what I make it
out to be in my head that's what enabled
me to like be funny and disarm those
people who at any time like I was always
the smallest do growing up I talk about
this in our show I was [ __ ] 5 1 till
I was 16 I got [ __ ] clown Don
repeatedly mm-hmm but the thing that
like didn't make me go home and feel
badly about myself is like I might be
5-1 but [ __ ] your hairline is dead
mm-hmm and I couldn't and I learned how
to make people laugh at themselves and
and and so for him to be like yeah they
can't fight oh [ __ ] them kids man kids
don't know [ __ ] it it yeah but that's
not that's not to say bully kids like an
older person right but you're not
bullying anybody that's what irks me
about this whole scenarios he wants to
come out here and act all high and
mighty oh you're bullying kids yeah I
mean like it I did have like it when
someone confronts you like that about
like what you do or whatever it does it
does make you take a second be like am I
am i doing something wrong am i mean
right yeah so I told him I said listen
like when when I when I create a 12 to
15 minute heat like a like a video right
I'm writing it out it's a it's a it's a
piece it's supposed to have an [ __ ]
narrative and all this [ __ ] right and
then I film it and I edit it there's so
many steps to that like process things
like make it's like anything else you
make it song you make a thing you can't
tell right away whether it's good or not
whether it hit the narrative that you
wanted to hit whether it you know I'm
saying so much gets lost along the way
so much gets
maybe it's maybe it is a little bit mean
and you just can't [ __ ] tell when you
first make it yeah right by the way the
nature of YouTube you put it out there
see what people say whatever and some
like maybe maybe some of the videos that
I've put out have been like a little bit
mean but that's never ever I don't sit
I'm not a [ __ ] we think I'm a villain
you guys sit down and I'm a [ __ ] to
students day up no I sit down with the
intention of making people laugh that's
what I want to do I want to make people
laugh yeah you know I'm saying I don't
sit down being like I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna [ __ ] tear into this guy I'm
gonna make him feel like [ __ ] yeah I
mean yeah well I guess more like I want
to make a million people laugh at this
guy with me about the ridiculous [ __ ]
this dude is doing yeah but that that's
I guess the point I'm trying to make is
when I say [ __ ] them kids like what I'm
saying is kids who watch Lele pons and
are entertained by that it would
probably do them some good to have a
second opinion to be like you understand
it this is a little bit goofy that there
is nothing there's no harm there and and
if [ __ ] lay lays representation or
Jake or hurt by people being like what
because in my opinion Jake projects
himself a little bit into that that was
a weird roundabout way of like he the
fact that he didn't even address that we
did a [ __ ] 15 minute video making fun
of him like he didn't bring it's weird
to me he didn't bring that up at all
mmm-hmm you know I'm saying yeah I think
the whole thing was kind of just about
that what like I almost feel like he
played it off like he was like like
there are other people that have talked
to that are affected by this but I feel
like think about that video right yeah
but that's what I'm saying like he wants
to come up in there and like this this
then the third act like he's [ __ ]
he's gonna come in and swing on you
any-any and he's and he makes it about
oh you're bullying kids yeah first up it
there is no [ __ ] harm in calling a
Lele pons video [ __ ] corny Hannah
stocking videos [ __ ] corny all that
[ __ ] is bad it's weak and and and it
doesn't matter if [ __ ] if like I I
just can't I can't make the connection
from commentary to bullying I don't know
how you get there yeah and I guess I'm
that's what I'm struggling with here is
I don't see how
he can honestly call that bullying I
mean like to just like to I guess like
play devil's advocate it's like I I do
like in that second Lele pons video I do
say that she's awful I'm like she sucks
she's mean hurt she's dumb she's like
I'm like I'm you know which is like kind
of bullying I'd say so maybe there is
like a lighter way I can you know maybe
I just was in a bad [ __ ] mood that
day and I sat down and wrote a video
where I was like a little bit more mean
I don't know man I think we okay I guess
I keep drawing from that scrunch but a
Tamil at the end of almost every video
after Maddie smokes we [ __ ] we make a
point to be like don't go [ __ ] with this
person yeah we always said don't go [ __ ]
this person you know like that you know
at the end of the day like these are
these are harmless jokes and and I feel
like we make a point here everywhere to
be like if someone if comedies are
somebody's expense it's like you're
saying we're not here to to ruin their
life and make them want to [ __ ] kill
themselves and all this and that but
that doesn't mean like we can't be
critical in a joking way of somebody
even saying [ __ ] lay upon sucks
take that on the chin dude take that on
the chin mm-hmm your own [ __ ]
entertainment yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah even like reviews and
[ __ ] variety or that harsh yeah what
the [ __ ] article that do wrote about
post yeah I mean there's that [ __ ] was
mean as [ __ ] it was like a six page
[ __ ] diss piece on them how about
this Jake you don't [ __ ] with bullying
how about you take down every video
where you've tied your girlfriend to a
[ __ ] wall and left her out there for
hours with duct tape how would you go
watch that [ __ ] video where I clowned
you for looking like a sociopath and you
look at all those moments you're
teaching that [ __ ] to kids you don't got
a problem with that yeah you don't you
ain't bringing none of that [ __ ] up
through this [ __ ] the [ __ ] that
just that hurts me man you eat you wanna
think I think he wanted to use the whole
thing it's like basically like like I'll
say kotico conquered yeah I walked in
there defeated him bullsh I'm out and
that's it and that's like that I was
like that that's not really the way that
you should like
I just don't think you've done a lot of
thinking about this I think that maybe
you saw us clown you on in a video for a
little bit and you were like [ __ ] this
kid yeah and then you just saw me as
someone who's who
you can real about I need to walk up to
and confront on a video and then walk
away from it it's like yeah cuz buddy
can't what I'm saying didn't punch me
so of course I'm not gonna punch you
this [ __ ] four cameras rolling he's
never ever gonna swing on anybody yeah
he's [ __ ] camera guy man that dude
that dude I was funny wasn't really
funny Jake Jake was like Jake was
probably being more civil than his
camera than his camera dude honestly his
camera dude was sitting there just like
he kept being like yeah he clearly he's
so clearly [ __ ] hated me I don't know
why I never met the kid man he's like
wearing these [ __ ] cuz you're not
allowed to make fun of Jay Paul dude I
get I guess not I mean like he's just
one of his yes-man I guess yeah it was
like wearing that like neon orange guest
shirt with a neon orange hat he look
like a high beast traffic cone sick yeah
what kind of foot I'm sorry man I don't
mean to get all animated about the [ __ ]
it's just like that like that [ __ ] his
sucker [ __ ] to the fullest bro goddamnit
that she's so corny turn the cameras off
oh it's good oh oh it's good it's
getting a real in here turn the cameras
off well he was like he was like turn
the cameras off turn the cameras off and
then he's like show him that it's off
and I was like damn is that really what
this come did you have to do that like
you it's not just like you trust that
people turn the cameras you know say
yeah yeah yeah like he had to get his
camera to just show me that it was off
and I was like man that's like when
you're at that point that means that
you're being it on yeah you'd most of
the time to weird [ __ ] just a bit and
then I'm like but like now it gets
honest and now you're gonna turn the
camera so this is a real moment like we
should actually gonna have a discussion
like man your [ __ ] thing yeah I'm
just dude I'm just like oh man sorry my
brain is just going a million miles an
hour on him getting on you for setting
an example after he does a [ __ ] 20
minute video with Tana
babysitting kids and they're talking
about [ __ ] each other and all that
[ __ ] all through the entire it's just
like that his his content is riddled
with [ __ ] if you want to get down to
cherry-picking and being like you did
this you did that you did this you did
that so it's just [ __ ] arrogant in my
mind to come in there one press somebody
while they're sitting in a [ __ ]
sitting in a chair yeah it's just so
lame someone is sitting down you're
gonna run up on them and like yeah your
eye level with my chest what's up [ __ ]
that's one and then two just I don't man
it's just that's lame
that's [ __ ] corny you will see we'll
see how that footage turns out maybe his
vlog today or tomorrow or some [ __ ] I
bet you I I you know don't blame me I'm
just saying don't blame me if I look
like a total [ __ ] yeah don't blame me
cuz you understand I've explained the
situation you know that I was I thought
the whole thing was a [ __ ] joke I
really did I was like and I was kind of
trying to plate up for the camera at the
same time because I'm like I want to
make Jeff's video good I want to make
this moment good yeah but I couldn't it
was so so confusing
[Music]